ELEANOR: Hi, my name
is Eleanor [INAUDIBLE],
and on behalf of the
Jewglers New York group
and the Talks At Google group.
I am so thrilled to welcome you
to the Google New York Hanukkah
party.
And, whoo!
That's what I like to hear.
And I have the pleasure today
of welcoming a very, very
special few guests.
So, we're thrilled
to bring them onstage
and without further ado, a happy
Hanukkah, to Neshama and Josh
in the encore.
[APPLAUSE]
Woo hoo!
[MUSIC - NESHAMA CARLEBACH AND
JOSH NELSON, "HAVA NASHIRA"]
JOSH NELSON: Try that.
You got it.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH NELSON: Give yourselves
a big round of applause,
you sound so good!
All right!
[MUSIC - NESHAMA CARLEBACH AND
JOSH NELSON, "Y'HI SHALOM"]
NESHAMA CARLEBACH: So this is
one of my most favorite prayers
in the world.
It's called "Y'hi Shalom."
May there be peace
in your borders,
and tranquility in your castles,
which is such a deep concept.
Can I have a bit more
of myself, please?
Can you imagine how beautiful
this world would be,
if we didn't only understand
the secret of having peace
within our borders, but
serenity inside of our hearts,
inside of our souls?
A world where nobody questioned
their decisions, a world where
there was no regret,
because it was clear
that every step of our
journey has taken us exactly
to the place we have to be.
We would have space
for ourselves,
space for each other.
To me, it's the answer.
Peace in our borders, and
tranquility in our castles.
And we are living
in a broken world.
We're also living in a
world where Google exists.
You guys better clap
for Google, seriously.
[APPLAUSE]
Where we're spreading our
arms wider, and opening
the doors wider, and
expanding our thinking,
and our consciousnesses,
and learning, and opening.
And changing how the
world sees the world.
So this is our
prayer, and you can
pray no matter
where you come from,
it's just sending some good
wishes into the universe,
and hoping that the higher
power, whatever it is
that's above us, is listening.
That's what we're here for.
So we hope that you will sing.
And that at this moment,
somewhere in the world,
there's going to be a new
glimmer of light and peace
and hope in somebody's
heart, just because we're
trying to send it there.
[APPLAUSE]
NESHAMA CARLEBACH: Thank you.
JOSH NELSON: So we got a
little bit of a medley tune
for you guys.
We're really lucky that we were
brought to a place of deepness,
I guess, by really important
mentors in our lives,
as is usually the case
when you find somebody
who sort of guides
you down the path
when you don't know
that you're looking.
And for me that was an
extraordinary musician
and teacher named Debbie
Friedman, of Blessed Memory.
And for Neshama, of course, it
was her father, the late Rabbi
Shlomo Carlebach.
So together, it's an
incredible blessing
to have sort of received
those teachings at a young age
and to have found
ourselves together
in a musical partnership now.
So this is a little mash-up of
two of their most best-known.
[MUSIC - NESHAMA CARLEBACH AND
JOSH NELSON, HEBREW SONG]
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH NELSON: Thank
you all so very much.
We're going to do one
more little quiet song,
and then we're going to
light some candles together.
I know there are kids that are
anxiously awaiting this candle
lighting, there's
a lot of pressure.
So we want to share this
little piece of music with you.
It's in English, but there's
Hebrew in the chorus,
and the message in the Hebrew
is a really important text
for our community--
"L'dor vador nagid
gadlecha," "from
generation to generation
we will proclaim
your greatness."
[MUSIC - NESHAMA CARLEBACH AND
JOSH NELSON, "L'DOR VADOR"]
JOSH NELSON: Thank you
all so very, very much.
NESHAMA CARLEBACH: Thank you.
JOSH NELSON: It was really
an honor and a pleasure
to be with you today.
I think we're going to have
an extraordinary lighting
of candles at this time-- wow.
This-- there's a first time,
this is a Shehecheyanu,
from me.
Is this your first
lava lamp menorah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
It's also my first
raspberry pie menorah, too.
It's an exciting day at Google.
[MUSIC - NESHAMA CARLEBACH AND
JOSH NELSON, HEBREW SONG]
JOSH NELSON: Let's just sing
together, come on. [INAUDIBLE],
here we go.
[SPEAKING HEBREW],
happy Hanukkah.
Thanks so much for having us.
NESHAMA CARLEBACH: Thank you.
Lots of love, and
blessings, and light.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]